the Joe Rogan experience bill birnes
sent me a [ __ ] horrible video
yesterday of this guy these two guys are
riding like [ __ ] on a bridge like
with motorcycles weaving in that traffic
and one guy loses control of the bike
and he hits the cement barrier on the
edge of the bridge and then goes off the
edge oh my god yeah just watch it bang
when he flies off it's like all I've
been seeing the last week - we just did
this here it is Jamie Goddard already
Jamie's the fastest Googler in the West
you're on it see these guys are funny
look at this oh he touched - yeah you
see him put his foot down and try and
collect himself watch yeah and watch
when you see when they pull over and you
get to look at how far this [ __ ]
dropped like he's done the guys got
anything on his pockets of course it's
floor it looks like it shorts Florida
[ __ ] [ __ ]
Florida probably landed right on an
alligator now shoot up yeah I read a
story in Florida but Tampa Florida
called it of course man a mess man I was
there for two weeks I was scared
shitless the whole time I've been
everywhere it's Florida I was like
paying attention to everyone
everything [ __ ] up happens there they
they just issued a shoot-to-kill
on iguanas they're trying to get people
to kill as many iguanas apparently
there's so many iguanas there that
they're digging holes under bridges and
roads and roads are collapsing yeah
buildings are collapsing look because
they're digging they're digging trenches
under the foundations not so crazy and
they're big like 5 feet long when you
got what's the smile on his face
Florida guano hunter mistakes pool boy
for you wanna shoot some [ __ ] together
guys come on not going to happen my
sister lives in floor she's probably
listening to this Laura get out of there
run run for your lives
it's a [ __ ] goofy place to live man
it really is
[Applause]